free agency begins in a week and we have
the top 100 posted at
profootballtalk.com if you're watching
on nbcsn or sky sports usa there are the
top 10. inevitably somebody's going to
pay too much for someone and they're
gonna regret doing it but that's what
happens every year in free agency so we
have decided to take a look back on free
agencies past and do a draft of the
worst free agent signings of all time
and chris
to determine who picks first we will
play our daily game of rock paper
scissors i stand corrected thank you
rock paper scissors are you ready to
lose rock paper scissors are you ready
ready here we go get it in the screen
and we can't see it center yourself here
we go i'm cheating here we go rocks
paper scissors shoot
yeah good eat that okay damn it i'm the
champ at this game i'm gonna you know we
haven't we've yet we've yet to have to
do it twice yeah i know you're right we
have had no ties um
all right my first pick i i you know i
didn't think i was gonna go here uh but
i i think i gotta take brock osweiler's
number one right off the bat uh i think
i'm gonna go there yeah you know first
of all i think for so many reasons it
was the worst signing uh we've seen
especially here in recent history but
you know here is brock osweiler who
didn't do anything special for that
denver broncos team in the 2015 season
you know beat the patriots in overtime
yes i get that but i mean we're talking
about one of the all-time great defenses
you know in the history of the nfl that
season and then he did get benched at
the end of the year for the worst rated
quarterback in football that year which
was peyton manning okay so yeah still
peyton manning i get that we could say
it's still this and still that but he
still wasn't worth the damn really at
the end of that year i'm just that's
just the way it was that's not me
chris sim said that peyton we know
you're listening chris sims
the football guys deserve to give him
that anyways because he had carried
other teams for a lot of years by
himself in a lot of ways so hey i have
no problems with that but brock oswert
then of course yes the denver broncos
don't sign it back they almost did but
then houston signs them without really
sounding like they had the due diligence
of the whole team and organization as
far as coaches and people studying
getting to know the guy all together and
then there he is the starting
quarterback for the houston texans for a
big amount of money uh with a team that
had been desperate for a quarterback for
a while so they made a desperate move
and got brock osweiler before they
really knew what he was as a person or a
player so i got to put that up there uh
as far as the the worst free agent
signing i certainly can remember here in
recent history
and you know i'm not here to make your
case even stronger but we do need to
mention that it ended after one year
between osweiler and the texans and the
texans had to give the browns a
second-round pick thank you take
osweiler's contract because the second
year salary of 16 million was fully
guaranteed i think it was 18 million
fully guaranteed either way second round
pick was necessary to get the browns to
take that contract off the books it was
a stunning trade when it happened and
osweiler will be a free agent again this
year i have a feeling he will not be
getting a three year 48 million contract
from anyone he'll be lucky to get signed
by anyone when he enters free agency i
was torn between osweiler and another
one and i i didn't know which way i was
going to go but you've helped resolve it
for me by getting the first pick albert
haynesworth to me when i think free
agency bust that's the first guy that
comes to mind because it was such a big
splash by washington and you know daniel
schneider trying to go out there and buy
himself a championship caliber team and
haynes and defensive tackle it's always
been a dangerous position defensive
tackle and running back because i think
those guys work so hard for that brass
ring when they get it they realize man
it really hurts like i'm getting blocked
by two and three guys and you know now
that i got my money i'm going to relax a
little bit and i'm not going to kill
myself the way i have throughout my
career and i think there's always a risk
with great defensive tackles that's what
makes what aaron donald did this past
year even more impressive because he
continues to bring it every single play
but they took haynesworth and what do
they do they they they had him for one
year and it was uh then the second year
they bring in mike shanahan and it's a
big mess and they change from a 4-3 to a
3-4 and haynesworth doesn't want to play
the 3-4 and it was just a distraction it
was ugly in hindsight they should have
traded him into the browns and given a
second round pick to get him off the
books after one year but hainesworth to
me haynesworth and osweiler both i'd say
co-worst
free agent signings of all time but for
me hanesworth just stands out a little
bit more because it was a microcosm of
the dysfunction that washington has had
for the last 20 years oh very good word
there very nicely done uh but yeah that
would have that i think if oswego wasn't
available that's really who i was
tossing it up with between albert
haynesworth and you know and oddly
enough i was on the tennessee titans
team with him when he was getting ready
to go into free agency and do all that
and there was all those rumors at that
time too that well you can't pay him a
big lump sum of money you know he'll
check out and i i kind of fought fought
against that at the time i wasn't sure
that he would be that type of guy i'm
not saying he was like you know the
hardest worker on the team or anything
like that but i did think he loved
football enough to where he would still
give enough effort to somewhat justify
that contract he got in washington but
he obviously uh you know she checked it
in what what do you want chris this
happens all the time we made this point
about landon collins right somebody is
gonna get this grossly wrong if there's
a team out there that will pay landon
collins the giant safety dramatically
more than the giants who have had him in
the system for four years somebody is
misevaluating landon collins and with
albert haynesworth the titans got it
right and washington got it wrong yes
there's no doubt about that and it was a
disaster and then hey he went to new
england after that let's not forget that
and we thought oh well new england will
get them straight and that didn't
exactly work either
okay i think my next one i'm gonna go
with dante culpepper okay the dante
culpepper free agent signing from the
miami dolphins right that one okay and i
don't even chris yeah chris i'm gonna
i'm gonna you know what since i like you
i'm going to do you a favor here and let
you pick someone else because he was
traded he wasn't a free agent sign
that's good fine save me because i
didn't know that so that's good i went
off total memory there so i can move on
to my next one that's no problem okay my
next one then will be how about adelius
thomas right do you remember adelius
thomas from the baltimore ravens thank
you for saving me the dante culpepper
thing i totally forgot that either way
adelius thomas at the time and i believe
this is the 2000 we're going into the
2007
season right he is look at that as oh my
gosh adelius thomas this freak
linebacker he could play safety he's so
athletic type of thing for the baltimore
ravens and the new england patriots
signed him in the offseason after the
2006 season and you thought oh wow this
is going to be some special marriage and
they paid him a lot of money which was
uncharacteristic of the new england
patriots especially now and especially
at that time but they and you thought
wow this is going to be the perfect
marriage here it is bill belichick's got
this guy that's going to do all these
different things and he's going to
dominate for this new england defense
well i'm not going to say he had a
horrible time in new england he was
solid but he certainly didn't live up to
what they paid him and they paid him to
be a difference-making type of
linebacker outside linebacker pass
rusher do all these different things and
that experiment did not work by any
stretch of the imagination and i think
it was maybe what three years he lasted
there in new england before that was all
said and done and they moved on so i
look at that as one of the uh worst free
agent signings i can remember because i
thought the player was gonna be pretty
damn good and i thought when he went to
new england oh watch out of course it
didn't work out
well and you know we've given the
packers a hard time in the past because
they rarely make a splash in free agency
the patriots rarely pay market value in
free agency adelias thomas and stefan
gilmore really the only two guys where
they've gone out and signed someone who
was a stranger to the organization right
because they're very concerned about the
guys in the locker room and when you're
getting guys to buy into taking less
it's hard to make that fly if you're
going to go out and pay big money to a
guy who has never
spent a single day as a member of the
new england patriots it worked with
gilmore and i agree with you it didn't
work with adele's thomas there are
plenty of others i can choose from i'm
not going to go kirk cousins i know that
you think that i will at some point
for sure
the jury is still out maybe if we do
this next year kirk cousins will be on
the list that's all the incentive kirk
needs to prove me wrong yet again i'm
going to go with elvis gerbach because
the ravens had just won the super bowl
after the 2000 season they let trent
dilfer go trent dopher was a quarterback
and it's not like he was johnny unitas
in baltimore but he was still a guy who
won a super bowl they pay elvis gerbach
a five-year 30 million dollar contract
11 million guaranteed that he made under
that deal and he lasted all of one year
with the baltimore ravens so i'm not
saying they should have kept dilfer but
boy they were in a great position with
that defense with that defense to go out
and upgrade at quarterback and they
thought they were getting an upgrade in
gerbach and they weren't and that was
that after one year gerbach was done
yeah that's a good one he was on my list
as well uh i i certainly thought about
that yeah that was one of those where
you know the ravens might have out
thought themselves there a little bit
and just stayed with the formula that
made them win the super bowl yeah dilfer
might not let up you know just lit up
the world as far as stats and things
like that but he played a style and a a
type of game that fit their team
ultimately and they tried to change
their team and throw the ball more and
be a different offense with elvis
gerback and they weren't quite as good
that defense was special but yeah it was
uh not a good look for the ravens or
elvis gerbach okay i think the next one
i'm gonna go with and i feel bad about
this a little bit because the guy was an
awesome player but i think i'm going to
go with nan namde asemua uh of the
2011 philadelphia eagle dream team the
dream team right and that's part of the
reason i'm taking him because he was
really the starting point for that
conversation nande asema and i want to
defend him here and make sure this is
clear was absolutely awesome with the
oakland raiders for the majority of his
time there he was one of the best
corners in football but when he got to
2009 2010 it was really good but not as
great as it had been and he goes to
philadelphia and they gave him a
five-year 60 million dollar contract of
course uh and that was the starting
point for the dream team and it was just
underwhelming from get go the
philadelphia eagles thought they were
going to get this shut down island
corner we can put him on anybody and he
will cover the other team's top receiver
well it failed miserably nande asemos
skill set started to fall apart you know
day by day basically and yes within two
years after a five-year 60 million
dollar contract he was out of there in
philadelphia and that whole
signing in general along with some other
players uh really affected that eagles
team through that time period
that's a good pick and you're right and
it was your your former texas colleague
vince young who when he was signed by
the eagles that in that rush after the
lockout ended and it was one player
after another and they're loading the
cannon they're gonna go for it young is
the one who coined that dream team label
and it was anything but a dream for the
eagles in 2011. all right i could go in
a lot of different directions with this
one and here's what i'm going to do i'm
going to do a combo okay
okay i'm going to go neal o'donnell and
larry brown because they were connected
in super bowl 30 they both became free
agents after super bowl 30. larry brown
was the mvp because he picked off neil
o'donnell twice and on one of them it
was like o'donnell was deliberately
throwing the ball
to the receiver messed up right yeah
well right
but still right but o'donnell goes to
the jets after that game and is a
disaster he was going to be there next
joe namath and he was anything but and
then larry brown goes to the raiders
hardly plays over the next two years
both of those guys so much focus in the
95 season and super bowl 30 particularly
and it just shows you that that teams
can get caught up in that oh and super
bowl mvp i remember happening with
dexter jackson after the buccaneers won
super bowl 37 and he went to cincinnati
and he never did anything there right
but together neil o'donnell and larry
brown linkedin super bowl 30 both became
free agents both were disastrous yeah i
mean they were it wasn't pretty i mean
it's cheating that you just took two
players of the last time
but it is your show so we'll let it go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports